Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and my Game of
Thrones Season 4 countdown continues.
We’re within 30 days of the premiere and
they just posted a brand new trailer with
a bunch of new footage with a really tall
surprise that gives us an idea for just how
quickly the plot is going to be moving relative
to the books.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing a month long video countdown to
the season 4 premiere.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’m even doing a weekly giveaway for each
new episode once the season starts.
So just like my previous breakdowns this is
going to be a shot for shot analysis of the
new footage.
I’m going to exclude anything that was in
a previous trailer.
Careful for spoilers in case you don’t want
to know anything about season 4.
Here we go!
Starting off with a nice closeup shot of Widow’s
Wail, Joffrey’s new sword made from smelting
Ned Stark’s valyrian Blade.
Then there’s a new shot of Sansa enduring
more of Joffrey weapon play time.
Which cuts to her recounting the Red Wedding
with new husband Tyrion.
She’s got a lot to cry about this season.
Next is a scene of Ramsay Snow joining his
father Roose Bolton.
As mad as Roose seemed for aiding in the Red
Wedding, he’s still not as crazy as Ramsay.
I always thought of the two of them like an
evil version of Ned Stark and Jon Snow.
More Sansa sleeping in a room that looks like
a cell and might as well be.
At least Tyrion isn’t making her sleep in
his bed.
Then we finally get another nice long scene
with Oberyn Martell talking to Cersei about
the value of revenge.
For people who haven’t read the books, this
scene is incredibly ironic.
Hopefully during the season they’ll explain
why that is.
They’re both looking for revenge.
Here’s another slightly better look at the
city gates of Mereen.
Then Barristan Selmy counseling Daenerys and
it flows nicely into a nice speech of hers
about bringing Justice to the city.
The shots of the unsullied army are all repeated
from previous trailers, but the next shot,
this guy is brand new and somewhat spoilery.
It’s the Titan of Braavos, the place where
Arya’s Dancing Master Syrio Forel and Jaquen
H’ghar are from.
Remember Arya’s coin, it’s a Braavosi
coin.
I’ll let you rewatch the episode if you
don’t remember his instructions on how to
use the coin and what it does.
Then there’s another shot of Daenerys' Unsullied
traveling.
They’re trying to give us a visual reminder
of just how big her army is.
I love the synchronicity of their movements
too.
Grey Worm is actually the one that commands
them, Daenerys gives orders to him and he
gives them to the Unsullied.
Then there’s my second favorite shot.
All three dragons.
Look at how much bigger Drogon is than Rhaegal
and Viserion.
They can hunt on their own now, especially
Drogon.
And it becomes a huge problem as they get
bigger.
It’s like trying to raise a wild animal
like a Tiger in your home.
At some point it’s going to get out of control
and hurt or in Dany’s case, flame broil
someone.
Remember the dragons only eat charred meat.
Extra crispy.
It’s followed by another new shot of Daenerys
trying to figure out how to be a real queen
now that she has all these people depending
on her.
She doesn’t want to disappoint them.
Quickly followed by Tyrion standing trial
in front of his father, Oberyn Martell and
Mace Tyrell.
With a nice voice over that mirror’s Dany’s
sentiment of not wanting to disappoint his
father.
Here’s another amazing shot of Tywin sitting
on the Iron Throne.
I just love the imagery here.
The real power of Westeros, currently.
Finally sitting in the visible place of highest
power.
This shot of the girl with the bow confused
a lot of people, but it’s just one of Ramsay
Snow’s girls from back when he was tormenting
Theon with Sex.
She looks like she joined Ramsay on a hunt.
Hopefully they’re not hunting Theon again.
Next is a new shot of Bran crawling beyond
the wall trying to reach the Three Eyed Raven.
The raven is guiding Bran to him with visions.
Then there’s another new shot of Oberyn
Martell and Ellaria Sand enjoying themselves.
And finally a new or at least better shot
of Jon Snow killing one of his former wildling
friends.
For a brief second I actually thought it looked
like the same actor that played Benjen Stark
in season 1, but it’s not.
So given that we’re only a few weeks away
it’s likely that they’ll release either
one more trailer or another long featurette
or season recap like last year.
A lot of you have been asking for videos on
different characters and history videos on
the great houses.
But I’d like to try and do a video just
focusing on the history of dragons in the
world.
My next Game of Thrones video will be that
Q&A tomorrow.
So I’ll try to get that Dragon video finished
by Friday.
Which is Pi day, 3.14 make sure to celebrate.
Until then click here for to watch the full
trailer again and click here for that Q&A
video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!